alors maxime j'ai plein de talent
expressément pour toi
le détecteur de mons mais non tu vas
venir me rejoindre et tu vas être face à
l'animal il va devoir dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
maxime je t'attends tu as des as évolué
sur votre truc
ce qui est bien c'est que hier j'avais
posé une question sa vie répondent aux
noms on respecte son activité
aujourd'hui surtout à quatre ça vous
dérange vous fermez votre gueule
[Rires]
maxime si je vais te poser une première
question pour voir si le détecteur
d'invention je marche bien ces routes
maxime
série
est-ce que tu t'appelles maxime
je m'appelle maxime tu dois dire oui
alors oui c'est bon tout est sous
contrôle
première question
est-ce que maxime tu es en couple
actuellement
oui
[Musique]
maxime
est ce que la personne ait dans le
milieu des médias
non la caisse soit vous avez les moyens
c'est ce qu'on peut répéter laquelle je
pense c'est la régie a l'air d'avoir
mère de maxime
[Applaudissements]
ce sens il est ce que la personne qui
est en couple avec vous
un rapport avec la radio la télévision
ou autre chose
m
non
oui autre chose pendant dix ans autre
chose en même temps c'est beaucoup c'est
ouvert quand même un maxime est ce que
vous êtes en couple avec à personne
depuis plus de six mois
oui
est ce que vous allez me papa dans maman
alors attention d'abord six mois est-ce
que vous avez mis papa dans maman martin
mais là aussi on va dire sérieux est-ce
que vous avez mis le zizi dans la csn
vous avez mis le kiki dans le freestyle
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pas ta question qui n'ont
frichti j'adore les montagnes russes
non mais on n'était pas là pour faire le
malin et d'experts d'avancé on sait
comment ça m'a coûté salvador m e toiba
est ce qu'il ya eu 6 i dans des êtres et
mick non pas à 10 dans dix ou si c'est
impossible
pourquoi pourquoi six mois non mais la
montée c'est la première petite amie
quand même six morts
alors donc là pour l'instant donc c'est
juste galocher me selon le détecteur un
détecteur il ya eu 6 8 en asie
ouais bien sûr anciennement peut-être
khamis un des fils électriques
c'est parce qu'ils y sont réalisées
ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
dégagez tu pars aux 45 minutes en facial
à cela va causer le brésil pas bravo
allez belle la france
alors pensez pas déjà au mariage
ah non alors
ça c'est vrai c'est d'ailleurs si vous
voulez être le témoin peut-être alors à
chaque fois j'ai été témoin d'un mariage
ils ont divorcé un accord alors il fait
c'est notre espérance
maxime vieu de poser une dernière
question
cela je vais faire le tour
maxime
est-ce que
je connais oui ou non la personne
réfléchit bien qu'elle nous pataugeons
les péchés bien c'est mal savoir la
vérité
normalement il n'a pas réfléchi et qui
s'apprête aventure ouais mais vous non
skieurs cyril a dit qu'il la connaissait
le maxi oui à l'idée de venir je vais le
laisser comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime gagné vous êtes libre jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
merci monsieur procureur ce qui va se
passer c'est que je verrai cuire toutes
ces réponses se faire l'analyse de cette
séquence ce soir chez moi
et demain on aurait droit à une enquête
de baba qui dit en quête de baba dix
résolutions de la faire et ça va très
bien vous cite un désaveu affaires
n'hésite pas à les faire au cours de
cette émission parce que demain il sera
déjà trop tard